- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael,
my one word is Believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all the major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today I'm going to talk about
the seven fundamental truths
that will change your life.
And as always guys, as you're listening,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and the more you write
it down for yourself,
the more likely it's going
to stick in here as well.
Enjoy.
(techno music)
Truth number one is, You Are
What You Consistently Do.
If you look at your calendar,
you look at what you're doing
on a daily, regular basis,
that is what's going to
determine your future path.
So if you eat one chocolate bar,
but the rest of your
day is pretty healthy,
you're going to be a healthy person.
But if you're eating junk, and more junk,
and then pizza, and then
Burger King, and more burgers,
and more junk afterwards,
and then you eat one piece of broccoli,
doesn't mean you're going to be healthy.
Working out once won't make
a big difference for you.
Working out three times a
week, or working out every day,
you'll see changes in your life.
And so if you apply that to your business,
if you have a goal, if you have a dream,
if you have something
and you want to pursue,
you are what you consistently do.
Doing it once is not enough.
Doing it once a week is
likely not enough as well.
If you have a plan, you want
to accomplish a big goal,
you need to find time every
single day to focus on it,
to take some kind of movement
so you build a momentum,
so that that dream happens.
You are what you consistently do,
not what's in the exceptions.
Number two is, Your Daily
Habits Set You Up For Success.
So in order to be what
we consistently are,
then you need to set up your day
so that every morning
you create the routine
that sets you up for that perfect day.
I'm a big believer that
the first habit that you do
sets you up for the rest of the day.
And so if you are
consistent with that habit,
then you're consistent
with everything else
that you want to do, so an
easy one is making the bed.
So if you make the bed,
then you're not just making the bed,
you're the kind of person who sets a goal,
and follows through.
And then you're much more
likely to do the next step,
and the next step, and the next step.
So a lot of people have a daily routine.
In an ideal world of,
I'm going to wake up,
and I want to make the bed,
and I want to have green tea,
and I want to meditate, and I
want to do some yoga after that,
and I want mindfulness, and gratefulness,
and I want to work out, and
then I'm going to start my day.
You know, you have this huge long thing,
which is possible to do.
But if your first thing is really hard,
if you're goal for example,
is I want to wake up, and I
want to go for a 30-minute run.
That run is painful.
Once you're running you're good,
but getting the shoes on and
going out the door is painful.
So it's much easier to
start with something simple.
Because if likely, if you miss that run,
you're going to miss everything else
that's part of your schedule.
But if you hit that run, you're
going to stay consistent.
So that morning thing, the
very first thing that you do
becomes super important.
It's why I created the
Hashtag BTA for you guys.
And what I wanted you to
do was wake up every day,
watch a video that inspires you
where you're learning something,
and then write Hashtag BTA,
with the number of consecutive
days you've left a comment,
to keep the streak going.
And it's not just giving you
the information in that video,
but you're the kind of person
now who follows through.
And if you start with that video,
you're much more likely
to do the next thing,
and the next thing, and the next thing.
And so create a daily
routine that supports you,
and sets you up for success,
and make the first thing super easy to do,
so that you're going to follow through,
and keep the next one going,
and the next one going,
and the next one going.
Number three is, Your Environment Matters
More Than You Think.
This is the reason why people say you are
the result of the five people
closest to you in your life.
Your environment really,
really, really matters,
and most people have big goals of what
they want to accomplish,
but they don't have the current
environment around them,
that helps support them
achieving that big goal.
And so look at your
friends, look at the people
who you hang out with.
Look at the magazines you're reading,
and the videos you're watching.
Do they consistently help
you become that person
that you want to become?
Are your friends pushing
you and guiding you,
and motivating you, and supporting you?
Or are they telling
you, "You can't do that,
"you're never going to make it,
"you're not going to have success,
"who do you think you are to go off
"and do that big scary thing?"
And so your environment matters,
because if you're hanging
around these people
who are just putting you down,
then what are you going to do?
You're going to have moments of boldness,
and then you're going to shrink back down.
Because you want to be here,
but your environment's keeping you here.
And so whether it's
joining the meetup group,
or watching YouTube videos,
or looking at your physical environment,
and what's on the walls,
what's on the background of
your phone and your computer,
you want to be around the
things that make you come alive,
and force you to think
big and bold consistently.
It's why I helped create
this YouTube channel,
it wasn't just for you guys, it's for me.
Because I want to be
around successful people,
doing big, bold, scary things,
so that I don't wake up and
just be comfortable every day.
So I'm still pushing myself to get up
and do bigger and bolder
things every single day.
The fourth truth is,
You Don't Need Anyone's Permission.
So, from my personal experience,
when I had to make a variety
of career changes in my life,
going from a police officer in training,
to going into sales, to thinking of being
a marriage counselor.
In all these things,
I needed to make sure
that I do right by me.
And so when I think of the life decisions
that I have made in my life,
I think of myself in
like in 40 or 50 years.
Let's say I'm lying on my death bed.
What kind of regrets
do I not want to have?
So I read an interesting blog
post by an Australian nurse,
who takes care of dying people.
She mentioned five things
that were in common
with a huge number people,
and what they worried about,
what kind of fears they had,
the kind of things they said.
Interestingly enough, three
that really stood out for me,
one, a lot of them said, "I
wish I let myself be happier."
Second point is, I wish I had the courage
to express my true feelings.
And the third one was,
I wish I had the courage
to live life to my true self,
and not live to someone
else's expectations.
So when you think of your life right now,
and if you imagine in 40 years,
maybe you want to try a new job,
maybe you want to do a dance class,
maybe you want to ask someone out.
Are you waiting for permission,
and the funny thing is sometimes
it's not from other people.
Sometimes it's just from yourself.
Sometimes you're getting in your own way,
because of fear of failure,
because of fear of rejection,
a variety of things.
I'm going to tell you right now,
it is an incredible feeling
when you let that go,
and you feel that you
deserve all the happiness
that's out there waiting for you.
Just make sure you consider it.
Next time you get excited about something,
next time you feel
passionate about something,
next time you feel a little bit scared,
but you want to try something,
just do it.
Don't get in your way,
don't let others get in the way.
You don't need other people's permission.
At the end of the day,
30-40 years from now,
I want you to make sure that
you're not living with regrets.
So be free, and be happy.
Truth number five is, Modeling Success
Will Shortcut Your Path.
Whatever you're trying to figure out,
whatever goal you have,
whatever ambition that you
want to go out and create,
somebody has already done it.
If they haven't done it exactly,
they've done it pretty closely.
And so the more that you
can look to their story
of how they went from startup to hitting
that first big objectives,
you can learn from that story,
and apply it to yourself.
If you look at Starbucks as an example.
Howard Schultz, the
founder, went to Italy,
and he was on vacation with his family,
and he saw how the coffee shop was
the center of life for Italians,
it was their third home.
They had home, they had work,
and then they had the coffee shop.
And the cafe was a sacred place
that people liked to
hang out and belong to.
He looked at the North American market,
and he saw the Dunkin Donuts of the world,
where it was just fast through,
you go in, you come out.
You know, you just get your coffee,
you get your caffeine, and you leave.
But it wasn't seen as that third home.
And so he thought, "Why don't
I just bring this concept
"to North America?"
This concept that had worked
for decades for Italians,
and just bring it to North America?
And that's how Starbucks
was eventually born.
And you can think of it as,
that's a meeting place for people,
that's where people like
to spend their time,
between home and work,
and so that model really worked for him.
Whatever goal you have,
somebody has already figured it out,
and by watching videos, or
by reading their stories,
or listening to interviews,
you can dissect it, and apply their rules
to help you accomplish the same goal.
Truth number six is,
Your Profits Will Come
From Your Passion.
If you look at anybody who's
had success in any field,
it's because they had massive
love for what they're doing.
You have to enjoy the work.
Jerry Seinfeld calls it the
torture that you can endure.
The things that you do,
that you could do day in and day out,
that you love so much that other people
look at your schedule and say,
"That is torture, that is crazy,
"I can't believe how much
time you spend on it."
People look at me filming
60 videos today and say,
"That's nuts, how do you
do that all in one day,
"it's crazy, I can barely
get one video up per week."
It's torture to them, but to
me, I love it, I breath it.
Helping entrepreneurs,
I can stay up all day,
and not go to the bathroom, and not eat,
and forget to sleep,
just because I love helping entrepreneurs,
and get so focused in that zone.
Where other people would look at that
and say it's torture.
That's what you need to find.
When you find that thing
that you love doing so much,
and find a way to be able to
apply it to help other people,
that's when you start making money.
Your money, your profits will
come by pursuing your passion.
Truth number seven is, You
Can Do What You Believe.
Believe is a big thing for me,
it's my one word, it's super important.
But I find it so saddening to see people
holding themselves back,
not accomplishing the thing that I feel
that they can do, that other
people think they can do,
but they just don't have the
self confidence in themselves.
There's an expression by
Henry Ford that saying,
"Whether you believe that you can,
"or you can't, you're right."
If you think that being 65 is too old
to start a company, your right.
But Colonel Sanders did
it, and tons of success.
If you believe that being 19 is too young
to start a company, you're right.
But lots of people have
come before you and done it.
There are people who
have way fewer resources
than what you currently have right now.
Whatever reason you're
giving yourself right now
for not being a success,
whether you're blaming your
government, or your country,
or your gender, or your size, or your age,
or your education, or your family,
whatever it is that you're blaming,
whatever the reason is,
that you think you can't be successful,
there are already people
who look exactly like you,
who come from worse backgrounds,
had less resources than you
currently have right now,
and they've gone off and achieved
much bigger things than you have.
If they can do it, you can too,
you just have to believe.
So that's my take on the
seven fundamental truths
that will change your life.
I'd love to know, what did you guys think,
which one was your favorite and why?
What are you going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life, or your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
Also, did I miss an eight, nine, 10,
that you want to add to the list?
Let me know by leaving a comment.
I also want to give a quick shout
to Anthony Avina.
Anthony thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and doing that review on your blog.
I really, really appreciate it man,
and I'm glad you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.